hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others
and I see a variety of questions that
are built up here
let me see
um
let's maybe start off with one from m
rudo what would a bio computer look like
so you know the computers that we have
today that we are used to using are
electronic computers they work by having
uh
electrical signals going through lots of
tiny wires and switches billions of them
in microprocessors
the what would it mean to have a bio
computer it would mean that the material
that was being used for the computer
wasn't Electronics with solid state
you know a a traditional microprocessor
is made mostly of silicon
etched to make these little wires and so
on it's really all a solid and there are
electrons that are going through these
little tracks and solid
what one would presumably mean by a
biocomputer is something which instead
of being made from
solid-state materials with etching and
all this kind of thing it's made from
biological materials
now in some sense we humans and all the
other biological Critters of the earth
so to speak are examples of biocomputers
in the sense that there are what is a
computer well a computer is in the end
something where you can run lots of
different possible computations on the
machine you can give different inputs
and the Machine can do follow different
rules to compute the answer it's I mean
the the bigger non-trivial fact about
Computing is that Universal Computing is
possible in the sense that you can have
a particular piece of computer hardware
a particular device and then by feeding
it different programs you can get it to
do different computations
and that's that's why in some sense you
can expect to have you know the same uh
I don't know word processor or something
running on computers of different kinds
with different computer hardware so to
speak
well so then the question is could you
take that thing that's running on a
piece of traditional computer hardware
that is solid-state electronics and
could you somehow deploy that on
something that is made of biological
materials
and although the things that we compute
are a little different from the things
that computers tend to compute in some
sense we biological organisms are doing
sort of computations
in in the way that they in in just
through through living and all the
things that are involved in living
they're effectively doing computations
now for example in our brains we like
existing electronic computers we use
electrical signals uh in the nerve cells
in our brains to be the things that sort
of carry information around our brains
in most of the rest of the way that we
operate as biological organisms we're
not using electrical signals that is
we're not using streams of electrons
effectively an electrical charge and so
on to carry information instead we're
transporting molecules around we're uh
we're actually moving maybe it's maybe
it's individual atoms of sodium or
potassium or something or maybe it's
actual whole molecules proteins that are
made of lots of atoms and so on we are
Computing things by actually moving sort
of material uh molecules and so on
around and one of the things that's
become clear in molecular biology in the
last few decades is that it's a very
orchestrated process
the uh what what happens it's you might
have the picture that biology is just
that we're all just sort of pots of
chemicals and that the things that
happen inside us are just the results of
chemical reactions from molecules kind
of in a liquid for example bouncing
around randomly and when two molecules
that can react happen to hit each other
then you get a chemical reaction
something happens it seems decreasingly
likely that that's what's going on most
of the time in biology it seems that
biology is full of kind of elaborate
orchestration where molecules are being
specifically moved along Little Fibers
where molecules have particular shapes
where they are all Orient themselves so
that they will expose a particular part
of the molecule so that some other
molecule can fit into the thing that's
exposed and so on it really feels like a
process where there's a sort of giant uh
piece of choreography of molecules
that's leading to the processes of life
and so it really it looks very much like
sort of a computation that might happen
in a in a existing electronic computer
except for the fact that it's happening
with moving around molecules and things
like this through perhaps things that
look a lot like wires the Little Fibers
in the in the skeleton of cells and
things like this and and different
things happening on the surface of a
cell and and ways in which for example
different pieces of molecules are
Exposed on the surface of the cell so
that they are arranged so that other
molecules can come notice that they're
there and all those kinds of things
so
that's that's sort of the the the
overall architecture of what seems to be
happening in living systems is something
that is in a sense very very
computational it's all about these
molecules moving around in very
orchestrated ways
now how do you program these things well
we don't yet know and it's pretty tricky
because the thing that seems to be the
most important about these molecules is
basically their shape
one of the things that's also kind of a
a big idea of biology is the notion that
you can kind of make a molecule of
essentially any shape just out of a
protein what is a protein well sort of
the other the sort of the ultimate thing
that we know about biology is we store
genetic information on DNA for us humans
it's six billion base pairs that are
sort of different segments of this DNA
molecule for a human if you stretched
out the DNA molecules that you'll find
in every single cell in our bodies it
will be a meter long molecule if it's
sort of stretched all out but
on that meter are a billion little
segments that could be A's or T's or C
or G's that essentially spell out the
genetic code for for a particular one of
us so to speak
well what's done with that genetic code
there are sections of it that correspond
to so-called genes and when uh at their
processes that cause that those sections
of the DNA to be transcribed and what
are they transcribed into in the end
every triple every three base pairs turn
into a single amino acid and those amino
acids are strung together it all is done
eventually by this thing called the
ribosome which is a little little kind
of machine-like molecule that um uh kind
of in which pieces of well it's actually
RNA which is one stage removed from DNA
but but the pieces of RNA are kind of
it's a big long strand of RNA which
contains the genetic code kind of goes
into the ribosome and extruded from
another part of the ribosome is a a
string of protein and the protein
consists of sequences of amino acids
each triple of base pairs corresponds to
one unit of amino acid the protein is
then the sequence of amino acids strung
together and it could be could be 100
amino acids it could be a hundred
thousand amino acids but the sort of the
the the cool thing in biology is that it
turns out when you have that string of
amino acids the thing will fold itself
up basically because well for example
there are sections of the of that
protein which tend to be hydrophobic
they tend to stay away from water and
they're ones that are hydrophilic they
tend to kind of expose themselves to
water and this kind of this this whole
molecule be very floppy but it will tend
to organize itself so that it kind of
has the minimum energy configuration
roughly the configuration where kind of
the the pieces of the molecule that are
most attracted to each other kind of get
to be stuck together and the pieces that
are repelled from each other repel from
each other but the thing will fold
itself up into this kind of potentially
blob that can be any shape and so in our
bodies there might be 30 000 different
kinds of proteins maybe a little bit
more and they have all kinds of shapes
like the actin protein that that forms
our our muscles is this kind of triple
helix that's a long stringy thing the
the protein hemoglobin that is in our
red blood cells there's a little cage
that just has a little space in it about
the right size for an iron atom that can
be used to kind of bind oxygen and
transport oxygen around our bodies and
all the different proteins that we have
they're all different shapes they're
sometimes globular really a blob that
sometimes they have these things called
Alpha helices which are these these uh
kind of spiral regions that are kind of
long and straight and so for example
proteins that stick through the membrane
of cells might have a an alpha Helix
that is the actual sort of tube that
goes through the through the the wall of
the cell but any case the the sort of
the big point is that it turns out that
so far as we can tell this isn't
completely understood the the kind of
space of possible shapes that you can
make with proteins is at least very
broad it might not in some sense be
every possible shape but it's a very
wide range of different shapes and those
shapes can be used as sort of puzzle
pieces that fit together to do all kinds
of things
and in a sense what one imagines is that
sort of a biocomputer is all about being
able to have the right puzzle pieces to
fit them together to do the things that
correspond to following rules that
correspond to the computations one wants
and by the way there's some more details
of this about how electrons are
transported on these molecules and so on
but but more I think the key point is
this sort of this the shape thing that
allows you to make these different
shapes of puzzle pieces and then sort of
see how they'll fit together so I think
the big difference between sort of a a
current sort of molecular scale computer
that's a biological one and an
electronic computer is probably that in
the biological one one tends to be
transporting molecules around whereas in
the electronic computer once
transporting electrons around now by the
way when people talk about building
quantum computers there's a whole story
about the relationship between quantum
mechanics and those computers which I'm
a bit skeptical about but the one thing
that is true about those computers is
the things that they use to kind of
store in information are different from
the things that traditional electronic
computers use electronic computers are
using the present sort absence of
electrons there will be quantum
computers that use ions uh kind of
pieces of atoms that use kind of little
Loops of of magnetic flux different
kinds of things that are used to kind of
store information well in the in the
sort of Bio case I think the main thing
that's being used to store information
is is probably the the presence of of
molecules of different shapes and so on
so uh you know I think that that's kind
of the um uh the picture of sort of what
a bio computer will tend to look like
now we have examples of things that are
very computational like the immune
system seems to be very computational
and it seems to consist of all these
different uh for example antibodies and
T cells and so on that all have sort of
different shapes and that all fit
together with each other and with sort
of antigens that come in and invade our
bodies and so on they they fit together
in this kind of shape kind of way
because they have these proteins on them
that are have different sequences that
cause them to have different shapes and
so the immune system is probably a good
example of a place where something very
very much like traditional computation
is happening but it's happening in a way
that is uh
um is is not trans is not going through
electrical signals it's going through oh
we've got a T cell and has this shape of
receptor on the side and it's going to
interact with the T cell with that shape
of receptor and that's going to lead to
this and it's all this kind of sort of
puzzle piece Cascade of puzzle pieces
kind of story
now people have tried well a variety of
kinds of things for molecular Computing
one that was popular for a while I
haven't seen so much of it recently is
dna-based Computing where what one's
effectively doing is saying uh one has a
a piece of DNA and it has this sequence
of base pairs on it and that piece of
DNA will
uh be it it will be able to let's say
you have a small section of DNA it will
with particular base pairs it will be
able to sort of puzzle piece into
another piece of DNA that has the the
kind of anti collection of those base
pairs on it and so what you can think
about doing is kind of using little
pieces of DNA as pieces of kind of a
construction kit to make different
shapes of things so people have made
things like nested patterns and so on
out of little kind of DNA tiles where
what's Exposed on the edges are these
kind of DNA sequences and so on it's
actual biology doesn't seem to do that
actual biology makes proteins and it's
the proteins that fit together in puzzle
pieces but it's it's rather easy to know
kind of what sequence you're getting
with DNA you can just literally have a
machine that that will essentially print
DNA at least up to some length with a
particular sequence and by making these
kind of DNA tiles you you can
potentially have something which fits
together with particular matching rules
and that's sort of a way to think about
doing computation
but I think that the uh the the real
story here is uh computation with
molecules and with shape recognition
rather than computation with electrical
signals and uh and pure uh Gates and so
on because you know in an electronic
circuit in an electronic computer you
just have electrons there and every
electron is the same as every other
electron
what and you don't have this possibility
of saying oh the actual things that are
carrying information they themselves
have kind of particular shapes or ways
of connecting to other things so I think
that's sort of the key idea that biology
brings and uh that we will eventually I
suspect have technology that kind of
matches and I you know it is sort of
nice to be able to kind of Leverage
existing biology and think about actual
ribosomes that evolved over you know
hundreds of millions of years or
something back a few billion years ago
an actual sort of the actual things that
are used in the different kinds of you
know the 20 amino acids that uh commonly
exist in in the critters of the earth
and so on to actually use all of that
apparatus that biological evolution has
developed for us but it's undoubtedly
the case that that's not the only way to
make sort of molecular scale puzzle
pieces and so on and my guess would be
that there will be more robust ways to
do that that don't have some of the uh
potential fragility and sort of
operating constraints of uh of
traditional biological
kinds of materials because remember
biology you know biological evolution is
only evolved to deal with organisms that
live in this tiny very narrow region on
the surface of the Earth and so on and
uh and then the oceans and things like
this
all right let's see
uh
well
there's a question here from RBS
can you grow life from a computer
program depends what you mean by life
you know I have to say my own view of
what life is has changed a bit
I think that
you know in ancient Greek times people
would say anything that can move itself
must be alive
but then there were steam engines
later on people said anything that can
have these chemical effects
must be alive but then there were just
uh explicit chemical reactions
discovered that that produce those
chemicals and so on then people talked
about self-reproduction the ability to
sort of make a copy of the thing you had
as being characteristic of of life but
then one realized that in computational
systems it's rather easy to make copies
of things and you know computer worms
make copies of themselves all the time
but I think
I I I'm still not really confident in my
current view of sort of what life is but
I think that the thing that is pretty
unique about life as it exists now is
this kind of orchestration of molecular
processes there are plenty of systems
like any old liquid where there are
molecules kind of running around in all
sorts of somewhat random and somewhat
organized ways but this this very kind
of structured kind of wire-like way in
which things are arranged in in
biological systems seems somewhat unique
now is it something where there really
has to be sort of explicit orchestration
I don't think so in fact the thing that
I realized uh oh sometime last year
actually was this thing that I call the
mechanoidal phase this thing where you
can have a very simple computational
system like a cellular automaton made of
a bunch of identical kind of idealized
cells and you can just have a particular
rule for that and when you look at what
the pattern that's produced by running
that rule what that looks like sometimes
it'll look very simple sometimes it'll
look very random and sometimes it'll
have this look that it has a mechanism
that it really means something that even
though it just got made from this rule
when we look at it we say that really
looks like somebody on purpose tried to
put all these pieces together
and I think that kind of meccanoidal
phase is something which is similar to
what we're seeing in in actual life
biological life and I don't fully
understand yet uh kind of how
how to characterize that and how to
think about the way in which kind of
this orchestration is necessary for
things like self-reproduction you know I
do tend to think that uh perhaps it's
confusing when we see these individual
organisms that uh you know that then
produce another organism and so on I
mean there is some sense in which life
is really just one structure that is
this giant tree of life of all the
organisms that have ever lived all
connected together all sort of giving
rise to other organisms and that what
one should really think about is the
sort of giant uh sort of graph of all of
those processes in all of those
organisms it's something that ranges in
scale from the kind of the individual
molecules that existed in creatures you
know a billion years ago to the things
that exist in you know whole herds of uh
of animals running around in the current
in the current world that that sort of
multi-scale thing is the story that
there really is only one thing that is
life on Earth it's all part of the same
object and there's just been one of it
uh now you know that kind of raises
questions about how did that start how
did one get that thing how did it get
produced uh you know were there sort of
some false starts and then this one that
really took off we don't know the answer
to that my guess is there were false
starts and there was one that really
took off and it's been going for a few
billion years and uh well we'll see
hopefully it'll keep going for a while
longer
so
let's see another biology question here
um from chriso
why are the different colors of flowers
but not trees
um
you know
why questions like that in biology are
funny
in the sort of way that biologists tend
to think about things the answer is
always it's that way because
it's evolutionarily good because it
makes the organism more successful
because it makes the organism have more
progeny which makes more of that kind of
organism and so on
that isn't always the explanation
sometimes there are physical processes
that essentially make a biological thing
that make you know the shell of a
mollusk or something and those physical
processes have what we might think of as
side effects oh it happens to also make
this pattern on the shell and
but what's strange about biology is that
biology has this tremendous habit of
sort of recruiting side effects you know
if it so happens that when you make this
bone shorter this happens and eventually
you know that means the creature can
stand on two legs and it can reach
higher on the tree or something that
thing which was sort of a side effect of
some Physics of how bones grew suddenly
gets recruited by biology to be
something that's really useful for
evolution so this kind of question of of
why do things happen and whether did
they happen that way because they make
the organism fitter and they make it
sort of more successful in the kind of
struggle for life and evolution but did
it happen that way just because it's
sort of a side effect of other things
that are going on
now when it comes to the colors of
flowers and things like that
it is interesting that there is a very
wide range of colors in flowers
and
it's
there are the actual way in which those
pigments are made is you know there's
physics behind what allows those
different colors to be made but there's
sort of a question of why have all those
different colors and by the way the
colors extend a bit into the ultraviolet
and so on and when we talk about colors
we humans
when there's an object a light falls on
the object what will happen is different
frequencies of light different
wavelengths of light effectively
different colors of light will be
emitted from the object
something like a metal
is often mirror-like so that any
frequency of light any color of light
that falls on the mirror will be
reflected from the mirror but other
kinds of objects well an object that is
like a blue flower for example uh what
happens is white light falls on the
flower white light is a mixture of all
different colors of light but if it's a
blue flower what that means is only the
blue light is reflected and the other
colors of light are absorbed but you
know when we humans perceive color we
just break all possible frequencies of
light into oh that's a red section
that's a green section that's a blue
section there's actually a whole range
of different possible uh sort of
frequencies of light that we humans
don't particularly perceive we only
perceive the amount that's in the sort
of red section the amount in the green
section the amount in the blue section
so different flowers I don't know the
details of this will have different
whole Spectra of kind of uh frequencies
of light that they reflect so we say
it's a blue flower but actually it's a
flower with a particular distribution of
frequencies
okay well so uh
you know so what
well presumably what's happening in
biology is that uh flowers
well flowers kind of uh flowering plants
that date from the Cretaceous Period
same time as the end of the dinosaurs
type thing last last period of the
dinosaurs
um flowering plants have sex or
reproduction and they need a thing like
a bee for example to go and take a piece
of of uh uh a cell from one plant and go
take it to another plant and or most of
the time they need that plants have
different mechanisms for getting
fertilized but that's a very common
thing you want a bee to go from this
plant to some other plants and so I
think one of the things that tends to
happen is you want the bee to go try and
fertilize another plant of the same
species because by definition if you try
and if you take that that um uh cell
from the from the first plant of one
species the species are defined by the
fact that they can't fertilize they can
only fertilize other members of the
species and not other species that's
kind of the definition of what different
species are and so you want the bee to
go from a plant of one species to a
plant of the same species and presumably
perhaps I don't know the bee is kind of
programmed to say oh that was a blue
flower there that looked like this let
me you know it's color coded let me go
fertilize the the other color of flower
of the the same color of flower over
there I don't know if that's right but
that seems like a a potential
explanation for why there will be a
diversity of colors because you're kind
of always trying to code in a particular
region you always want the kind of the
flowers of of the the B is to go from
flowers of the same color meaning
flowers of the same species now it's
kind of a fun question if you have a
whole bunch of different colors of
flowers and you know if there's a blue
flower here and a blue flower you know
where I am in in Massachusetts and
there's a blue flower in the tip of
South America it doesn't really matter
because no Bees gonna fly from one to
the other but the question is if you
have a whole sort of field of flowers
and some are blue some are red some are
green some are yellow
can you is it under what circumstances
can you sort of arrange the field so
that you have kind of mostly kind of the
the right colors of flowers in a place
so that the bee will tend to not get
confused it's kind of a similar problem
to if you have a map of the Earth and
you're trying to fill in colors for
countries you want to figure out how to
not have two countries of the same color
next to each other and sort of a result
in math that was finally approved in the
1960s although long long thought to be
true is a so-called Four Color map
theorem that says given a map of the
Earth on the surface of a sphere you can
it's sufficient to use only four colors
you can always color any map in such a
way that no two adjacent colors no two
adjacent countries have the same color
by using at at most four colors and so I
kind of wonder what the analogous result
is for for flowers in kind of a field
that will be pollinated by bees now I I
think in the case of of trees uh the
mechanisms of of fertilization are a bit
different they're things like they'll
have some piece of fruit that falls on
the ground gets eaten by some some
animal and and then it uh excretes them
somewhere else and that that will
fertilize another tree I mean you know a
thing to realize is trees have to be a
certain distance apart and so their kind
of methods of of getting fertilized will
tend to be things that want to have
their children not living too nearby so
they'll want things like they'll either
be blown by the wind some distance away
they'll have an animal that's going to
walk around for a while before it
excretes excretes the seed
um those those types of things
um
and I think uh yeah I should have
explained also that the um the way that
that plants get sort of fertilized that
the flowering plants they have pollen
pollen has these kind of weird shapes
pollen is is made from it has a kind of
a hard it's it's proteins but then it it
has these um
gosh what are they made of I think
they're
aluminosilicates maybe I'm not sure that
there's kind of these cages that get
made in pollen that are very funky
shapes I mean sometimes they're
polyhedrals sometimes they have spiky
pieces and so on and again that's that's
all I think part of the mechanism to
make sure that it's sort of only pollen
of the right species that gets gets used
in uh in the other plant
so uh
gosh let's see
um so I think my answer is I'm guessing
that colors of flowers have to do with
sort of getting things like bees to be
able to recognize which ones to find and
hummingbirds and who knows what else
whereas with trees it's uh it doesn't
really matter that's a it's a different
story now an interesting question that I
absolutely don't know the answer to and
I've wondered about for a long time is
the shapes of leaves on trees
they're quite diverse from an oak leaf
to a a maple leaf to uh uh to a pine uh
to a fur tree et cetera et cetera et
cetera there are all kinds of different
shapes of leaves why are there those
shapes
nobody knows a little bit is known
there's sort of a a biological evolution
type theory for the fact that uh in
tropical places it's you know when a lot
of uh
um moisture accumulates on a leaf it's
useful to have a little drip tip at the
end where the moisture kind of kind of
uh gets gets pulled there and then drops
off the leaf so you don't have your Leaf
covered with water but beyond that the
shapes of leaves I don't think anything
is really known about why leaves are the
shapes they are now that why question
again reflects back on sort of
evolutionary biology why is this an oak
tree need leaves of that particular
shape
um why does that make it more successful
well maybe that isn't what's going on
maybe it's just a side effect of some
other feature of how oak trees work that
they tend to have leaves of that shape
that's my guess actually
um and that it really doesn't matter
much what the shape of leaves are it's
just kind of a reflection a side effect
of other features of how oak trees work
that they have leaves of that shape it's
something where
I've long been curious whether if you
look at all the different shapes of
leaves that exist on plants of the earth
whether all possible shapes as generated
by some particular method for sort of
generating these shapes will be realized
or not I don't know the answer I've
always I've thought for ages about about
setting up a kind of global Leaf project
that might be done by by young kids
actually go collect a bunch of leaves
and I suppose I should rethink about
this because you know I last thought
about probably a decade ago and you know
young kids with smartphones was not so
much of a thing it's now pretty firmly a
thing and it's a question of you know
you get a leaf you pick it up you
photograph it and you feed that all into
some database somewhere and then you try
and sort of pick out the shapes of
leaves and where do these different
kinds of leaves grow what is the
distribution of shapes of leaves uh it's
I mean it's it's something that isn't
known and we don't know what would cause
it and we certainly don't know the
answer the why question about why one
leaf is one shape and one is another so
that's a a um you know that's sort of a
boundary to knowledge now I have I must
say that I in the case of flowers uh I
think somebody at uh our High School
summer
program maybe a couple of years ago uh
took a bunch of pictures of flowers a
project I suggested take a bunch of
pictures of flowers and just try to see
how the different colors of those
flowers are distributed in color space
um and I'm trying to remember what she
concluded uh no one has to look it up I
think
um I my impression is that there was not
uniform in color space now what would it
mean to be uniform in color space
because the way we assign colors to
things and this is what I was sort of
explaining earlier it's very
human-centric we'll say how much red how
much green how much blue
actually
to get a more uniform color space we
usually use coordinates XYZ which are
essentially the amount of excitation of
our red green and blue color cone cells
in our in our eyes uh it's a slightly
more complicated thing but it's roughly
the amount of red green or blue
but it is not obvious that a uniform
distribution in in red green blue space
corresponds in any particular way to a
uniform distribution in the space of
colors as seen by bees for example these
have a different visual system BC some
distance into the ultraviolet I'm not
sure how many kinds of color receptors
bees has I have I'm kind of guessing
it's more than our three but I don't
know how many uh the the all-time winner
I believe is the mantis shrimp which has
like a dozen or 15 different kinds of
color receptors which presumably is
important for recognizing different
kinds of of of of of of of plant and
animal life uh you know in the ocean
that the shrimp finds important for what
it's going to eat and things like this
uh
okay I'm seeing lots of questions here
about things like this well I see Paula
asking what causes a four-leaf clover
why are they so rare
well okay so there's this whole
phenomenon of so-called phylotaxis just
Greek for kind of the making of of of
leaves and so on it's when a plant grows
it uh
so
well different kinds of plants grow in
slightly different ways but there is a a
region of kind of active growth so okay
big difference between plants and
animals plants have rigid cell walls
animals do not
so once you've laid down a cell in a
plant it's got uh
um
oh my gosh what is it called uh begins
with c oh my gosh forgot the word the um
the kind of scaffolding of plant cells
um
cellulose is not the thing
well anyway there are there are rigid
cell walls for plants animal cells don't
have rigid cell walls if you have rigid
cell walls that means that whenever you
grow you can never kind of squidge
around what you already grew so for
example that means growing in a
tree-like shape is a good deal because
you can grow one little piece of the
tree you go out the branches you grow up
more branches you go out more branches
you can fill a lot of space with that
in an animal you can sort of start
growing and you can it happens very
commonly it happens even in the very
beginning of all of us animals when from
a fertilized egg cell just starts
growing more more cells and they just
keep on sort of coming in and they keep
on sort of squidging around and they
eventually make this kind of sphere of
cells and so on and a new cell cells
divide a new cell is produced but
everything is soft so the cells can kind
of push on each other and just make a
whole sphere that doesn't work with
plants
um the uh uh I guess it just cellular
cells the the once once a plant cell is
there it's rigid so you have to kind of
in your strategy for growth you have to
take account of that
so
the typical where a plant grows is
there'll be some growing tip of the of
the of the stem of a plant it's called
the apical meristem it's a particular
collection of cells that are dividing at
the tip and there where how the plant
grows
um and uh for example I think uh if you
the heart of palm that is the um that's
on a palm tree it kind of just grows up
the trunk and it's always just sprouting
leaves at the top that region at the top
has this apical meristem which is a very
kind of uh
um very kind of Rich uh thing sort of
full of nutrient
um that you can get in little cans and
eat
um but that's the the sort of special
cells that have this division capability
in plants
okay so when there is this area where
there are dividing cells that's where
the plant organs things like leaves they
come out from that area and so what's
happening is the um when the plant is
growing the Clover is growing whatever
else eventually it will grow this this
it'll be filling in cells and they'll be
making these rigid walls and then
there'll be this moment where it it it
decides for some reason that it will
kind of uh make a sprout you know it'll
make a leaf or something
well
the the question of how does it decide
where to make that leaf
well it decides based on plant hormones
um
auxins
boy I'm having a a difficult day with
words here plant auxins which are the
analog of our kind of growth hormones
and
what happens is and for example if you
do tree surgery and things you can
inject hormones into into a tree to get
it to produce a sprout in a particular
place to produce a branch in a
particular place
but what's basically happening is the
decision of where the Sprouts will come
out is determined by the concentration
of this plant hormone and so what
happens is where there is lots of
hormone
you'll get a sprout but once the Sprout
has been produced it kind of uses a
bunch of hormone to produce that Sprout
and so hormone will be depleted in that
place and so there won't be another
Sprout immediately in that area so then
if you look at a kind of a growing stem
they'll be sort of around the rim of the
stem there'll be a certain density
certain amount of plant hormone in
different places around this rim and as
the plant kind of grows it will kind of
get transported up vertically up sort of
the stem of the plant okay every time a
sprout comes out you deplete the plant
hormone on that side
and then what happens is the next Sprout
and maybe you're building up more and
more plant hormone and when the plant
hormone gets above some critical value
then another Sprout comes out
so an interesting math fact which I
rediscovered in the 1990s I guess it's
been discovered this fact has been
discovered like oh probably 30 times
since probably the the early part of the
20th century
it turns out that in this kind of setup
where you have this kind of ring of of
of concentration of of something like
plant hormone and you keep on sort of uh
removing a piece of plant hormone on one
side and then you ask well where does
the plant hormone build up it turns out
that the way it works is it will on
average the place where the next Sprout
will come out is 137.5 degrees away on
the circle from where the previous spout
came out and that's that's a fact that
you can deduce from just doing a bit of
math and it's related to the golden
ratio and so on but what happens is
that's kind of the the typical angle
between successive Sprouts on a on a on
a stem of a plant so for example if you
look at a palm tree you'll see that the
um the leaf scars on the um on the trunk
of the palm tree you'll you can see them
going around in kind of a spiral and
that spiral will have the feature that
if you look at sort of where does the
next one show up uh kind of um around
the trunk it's 137 degrees away
and the same thing happens if you look
at a daisy for example and you look at
the little uh stamens in the center
little yellow things in the center you
kind of follow them back to where they
were produced from the stem of the plant
you'll see the same exact phenomenon
this this uh 135 that's 137.5 degrees
and and that fact that golden ratio
thing means that when you start counting
where how many of these things there are
in a particular region you get Fibonacci
numbers one one two three five eight
numbers where the um uh the the
the a particular Fibonacci number is the
sum of the two previous numbers in the
sequence
um and that and the ratio of successive
numbers eventually becomes the golden
ratio about 1.618 square root of five
plus one over two
um the uh uh and that that's all related
to the angles in these plants but the
the cause of it is this phenomenon of
you just have a sort of plant hormone
building up again getting depleted on
one side and then you kind of are
looking at the effect of many different
depletions and quite quickly that sort
of it it goes to a steady state where
the kind of the next place where there's
the least depletion is 137.5 degrees
away if you look at different kinds of
plants whether it's a pine cone whether
it's a strawberry all these kinds of
things you'll find the same angle all
over the place
okay so that's the the most typical form
of phylotaxis is this uh Fibonacci
spiral phytotaxis
but there are other forms of value taxes
that happen there are some plants where
you have the spout of the plant and it
will just produce leaves on opposite
sides
um by the way people make a big thing
out of the fact that if you have this
137.5 degree thing that means that the
the higher leaves uh the well the lower
down leaves are minimally shaded by the
higher leaves uh and but you know it's
one of these things that's very
complicated in biology because yes
that's true but the math that leads to
that is identical to the math that leads
to this statement about how depletion of
hormone works and so on so the question
is what came first and my strong guess
would be this depletion of hormone thing
came first that's the mechanism so to
speak but then the plant kind of said
goody that means my lower leaves don't
get a shaded from the Sun so it's all
good and there's no big change in in how
the plan actually grows
but so the uh the thing that presumably
happens in a clover for example is that
you're building up plant hormone and at
some point the the the way the thing
works is it produces some some of these
Sprouts now I I think it's it's
complicated because this little place
where there's a this little growing tip
tends to be a polyhedral shape and it
tends to actually have cells of
particular shapes and they divide in a
particular way and they make and so my
guess is that in a typical Clover that
there's actually some actual shape of
cells in the little growing tip uh that
divides there and my assumption would be
that it is uh uh that what happens is
most of the time the total amounts of
plants hormone that need is needed to
get any sort of leaves to come out
when it gets above that threshold it
produces you know three uh leaves but
just sometimes uh it has enough extra
that another Leaf gets produced there's
enough plant hormone to produce another
leaf
my guess is that's how it works now uh
cam one could one compute what the
fraction of sort of four leaf clovers
should be
um uh probably in some first
approximation probably yes by looking at
um uh kind of the
well I'm not I'm not sure but but um
looking at features of this plant
hormone I mean it's worth remembering
that in biology sort of
everything is approximate in some sense
and biology has this feature that it
often tries to turn the continuous into
the discrete so for example let's say
you're making a zebra and it's going to
have black and white stripes
well what happens is that there's a uh
in the growing zebra and the zebra
embryo there is particular chemicals
that diffuse through the zebra embryo
and they also react with other chemicals
and those produce kind of chemical waves
and the chemical waves kind of go up
smoothly and down smoothly and so on but
there's a particular mechanism in the
growing zebra that kind of switches on
black pigment or switches It Off it's
usually these things called Hox genes
that are particular uh particular just
switch basically uh kind of protein that
acts as a switch where it says if
there's more than this concentration of
this uh
hormone-like substance then uh start
producing protein and if there's less
than that then don't produce protein
that's a pretty common mechanism in
biology above a threshold something
discreetly starts to happen below a
threshold it doesn't and so that's the
kind of thing that leads to oh you know
by the time you have this amount of
something to make something happen
usually it'll make three of it but just
sometimes it'll make four of it
it's same thing with with you know
fingers for example you know most people
end up with five some end up with six
um and you know it's rare but it happens
and it happens because when there's this
kind of switching that's going on it is
the switching something was a little
different in the concentrations you know
the concentration got a little bit
higher before the switching started to
happen or something like that and so you
ended up with something which wasn't
exactly five it was only approximately
five
um
okay let's see oh my gosh there's some
uh
capitalist says it says the mantis
shrimp apparently has 12 types of cone
cells inside do I have an intuition
about what the space of all these colors
occupy in the brain of the animal it's a
very interesting question you know
imagining what we can't imagine so to
speak imagine what imagining what we
have never experienced is really hard
for example you know it's perfectly
possible to have infrared cameras it's
perfectly possible to sense uh
distributions of like frequencies beyond
what we normally pay attention to of red
green blue and you know with the coming
generation of augmented reality virtual
reality kind of headsets and so on will
have every opportunity to take what is
usually in our visual field with usual
colors and add in oh we've got a sensor
that can also tell us about the infrared
the kind of the heat for example coming
off some particular object
but
the question is how do we how do we
project that into our brains how do we
how do we you know we're using up our
brains know about these three colors RGB
basically if we've got more colors to
tell our brains about how do we show
that to our brains because our brains
have you know in our primary physical
cortex we've got cells that are
responding to red and green and blue and
so on starting from the cells in our
retina that respond to those colors of
light and the question is you know how
do we feed in another seven colors for
example you know what would we do
I don't know and I think as we go to
higher levels in visual processing it's
kind of like uh you know what what does
it seem like to us now at some level
what we're doing in our visual
processing is always to try and sort of
reduce information I mean when we get
that first image on our retina we've got
10 million different sort of points of
light on our retina
um yet we don't as we look around we're
not saying oh my gosh there's 10 million
things coming in here we're saying
there's an object it's a camera looking
at me you know whatever it is it's an
object I'm not distinguishing all of the
individual pixels that are part of that
camera my brain is is taking this kind
of higher level object and that's what
I'm kind of taking out of it and I
suspect for the mantis shrimp it's kind
of the same thing it says there's a fish
of a particular kind you know that's a
fish I can eat that's a fish I can't eat
that kind of thing and it's kind of the
brain of the mantis shrimp is probably
taking all those colors and kind of you
know pulling it up into this kind of uh
uh summary that's a summary of objects
now you know the interior design of the
Manta Shrimp House so to speak that's a
different question you know what goes
with what color for the mantis shrimp
what is the kind of uh what's the kind
of almost
um uh subconscious reaction to colors
that it would have same with us I mean
again I think it's a very interesting
question how we to take additional
sensory data even like infrared or
ultraviolet and kind of mix it with the
data that we already have and how do we
build up a Model A Sort of perception
model that incorporates those additional
kinds of elements of of input
um
let's see comment from memes here
there's been a lot of cool research in
regard to photosynthesis recently to
have something to say about that
photosynthesis so photosynthesis is the
process of um uh chloroplasts and plants
and particularly the the uh the protein
chlorophyll being able to take light
from the sun and being able to
essentially produce energy from that or
more particularly produce kind of
um uh it has a
uh electron Cascade that it produces
that is what leads to kind of uh
chemical reactions that um can produce
energy for the plant
people didn't understand for a long time
how chlorophyll could possibly work
and what seems to be the case and I
don't know the details of this but what
seems to be the case is that there are
subtle sort of quantum mechanical
effects which are leading to the
possibility of of uh photons of light
producing the effects that they have in
chlorophyll and my impression is that
what's happening is there is an atom of
oh gosh I should know
um some metal I think
oh which one is it uh not Cobalt I think
maybe
manganese perhaps
um anyway some
some metal that's held in this little
tiny cage inside the protein that is the
um the the chlorophyll and that somehow
that uh has some kind of uh and very
sort of Amplified interaction with the
photons of light I I think it's a little
bit like
the way that
um uh a um
um
an uh an OLED organic light emitting
diode displays work where they are kind
of exciting
um atoms that are held in kind of a um
uh in that case in a solid state kind of
um
in a little kind of um uh trap produced
by sort of the way the semiconductor
Crystal works I think it's a sort of the
inverse kind of thing in some way in in
chlorophyll that it's kind of the the
photon that's coming in kind of has a
sort of a outsized kind of resonant
effect on on this particular atom and
that that sort of a key part of how
chlorophyll works and it's something
where sort of the most obvious
calculation would say it shouldn't be
able to work now you know interesting
question can we sort of use chlorophyll
or something which has the idea of
chlorophyll to make a make a better
photovoltaic a photovoltaic is something
that's using these days semiconductors
to have you know Photon light comes in
electron goes out that makes an electric
current that that allows you to produce
electricity from light
um is there a way to use some idea it
comes from the way that chlorophyll
Works to make a better one of those I
think the general thought is that there
may very well be but we don't know what
it is yet
all right let's see maybe
uh
gosh prob is asking what's the
difference in a species and a variety
how do you know if something is the main
species or its variety I think you know
what is the species well the traditional
definition of a species is
you can mate if you're the same species
you can't mate of your different species
but it's very fuzzy like for example
horse and Donkey meets to produce a mule
but the mule can't then mate with
anything is is then is then not capable
of of having uh you know mule babies
um the uh
and so that's right on the edge that
horse and Donkey are kind of close
enough together
um that they can still successfully mate
and I I don't know to what extent it's
really a question of like like with the
pollen and so on of you know what fits
in what type thing and to what extent
it's a uh you know what at the
macroscopic a large scale or the
molecular scale how that works but
that's sort of the traditional
definition of species is that they are
uh sort of reproductively isolated that
the the you know within the species
they're all mating with each other but
they can't mate across different species
now varieties tend to be our breeds and
so on tend to be sort of subparts of the
species uh where you get sort of
different characteristics of the species
but mating is still possible so for
example for dogs you can breed dogs so
you've got a giant Saint Bernard or a
tiny poodle and uh now you know bad
things happen if you mate up uh you know
if you if you made a male Bernard with a
female poodle I think the results are
not good because I think the the growing
fetus just sort of gets too big and and
it's bad news
um so but it does manage to produce a um
uh you know a a growing little dog fetus
um it just doesn't sort of mechanically
work but I think the um uh the thing
that uh that's again different breeds of
dog have been sort of separated off they
have different characteristics but they
still have enough they have still have
the same genetics they still have the
same things necessary to because because
one of the things that has to happen in
in reproduction is that the DNA of the
kind of the mother and father
organisms have to be kind of matched up
and if that doesn't work then it's kind
of game over in terms of making the um
uh the the sort of the the the new
organism because it's going to it's
going to use some stretches of DNA from
the mother some stretches of DNA from
the father on every chromosome there's
maybe only about five crossovers so it's
big stretch from mother from father and
so on and if it's different species
where the DNA has been kind of mixed up
then that's just not going to work
you're just not going to have the um
you're going to miss you know a big
chunk of DNA that was the thing
necessary to make a tail or something
like this
and um and so you know that that's I
think the the reason that doesn't
doesn't work there but but of course
you know the the Saint Bernard versus
poodle that's also encoded on the DNA
but somehow the DNA hasn't sort of moved
around enough that it can't get matched
up to make a viable organism I suppose I
mean it's also the case that in um
uh
uh you know
varieties breeds and so on can be very
different in appearance
um yet they're sort of core genetics is
somehow similar enough to allow this
kind of uh reproduction to work and I
guess you know the question would be at
what point do you when you breed things
separately at what point do you get
Critters that form different species and
that's not a well understood thing
um and I think uh I'm sure there are by
now experiments on that
um
and uh but I don't think it's I don't
think there's a good sort of theory of
how that works and it's like well how
many
you know how many changes do you have to
have before you have that now again
there can be these purely sort of
mechanical things like the Saint Bernard
is big and the poodle is small and that
doesn't work for mating very well
um and uh and so there can be things
like that that lead to kind of
reproductive isolation independent of
the fact that uh you know the DNA
doesn't match up
but I think um
um
yeah I I think this whole question about
when's it I ones that are different
species and one's at a merely a um a
different breed a different variety it's
a tricky thing I mean for plants for
example there can be very fixed genetic
kind of
um uh you know very fixed genetics
across a very large number of plants
they're sort of cuttings that can go
from one plant to another and for
example for us humans we can even detect
that rather well because for example I
don't know if you look at something like
apples you know a given variety of Apple
you know a Golden Delicious I like those
ones
um is a very specific genetic sequence
and they're all kind of identical all
those apple trees are identical enough
that they basically are making this
using the same genetic sequence if you
change the genetic sequence we our taste
system will detect that and we'll say
that's not a golden delicious apple
that's that tastes different
and so that's a and that causes all
kinds of issues like with bananas that's
caused all kinds of issues because
there's kind of this very specific clone
that's very specific thing that got
infected with various kinds of diseases
and parasites and so on and then all
those ones died off and it's a whole
whole long tail of Woe but um uh that
that's um it's interesting that we sort
of our taste system is sensitive enough
to pick up those kinds of things
okay I think I need to get going here
although there's one last question from
kefilis here
um
uh could it be possible to disable some
kind of uh cone cell in our eye and thus
lead someone to perceive Super Color
something that activates the other two
types of consoles while not activating
the other type in a way that is not
physically possible the problem is
we've got three kinds of cons cells
if one of them isn't working
then you are for example red green
colorblind
um
it turns out the females of the species
sometimes have two different kinds of
blue cone cells which can lead to kind
of super perception of color
um because uh if their brains you know
if they kind of they will their brains
will wire up for this uh because that is
as is carried on the X chromosome and
females have two X chromosomes that
means that they can be two different
kinds of of uh blue cone cells and that
can lead to this kind of super uh super
uh perception normally if you remove a
type of console you'll just have some
kind of color blindness now interesting
question there are Gene therapies that
um try to add back in retinal cells to
treat various kinds of genetic diseases
so it's a very amusing question whether
we could have a genetic uh something
that is put in there by let's say a
retrovirus or by
a gene editing crispr cast 9 mechanism
or something like this that is an
additional kind of cone cell and where
we could sort of be you know be just
growing some new kind of cone cell in
our eyes problem is you have to have the
whole system be sort of updated for that
to be there because you've got the
fibers in the optic nerve and they're
going to the primary visible cortex and
it's not obvious that you know even if
you have a new kind of cone cell it's
not going to get wired up in the adult
brain it's going to be really difficult
to wire that up maybe you know in in
well for example below age of 506 or
something even if for example you get
amblyopia where one eye has not been
operating properly and the Brain kind of
only programs itself for the for the eye
that is working properly if you patch
the eye that if you fix the Optics of
the eye and then patch the eye that was
working properly the brain at that age
will kind of relearn how to see with
both eyes so to speak and so probably at
that age if you were to sort of inject
kind of the uh the the sort of the
additional cone cell Gene editing kind
of thing
um you might be able to successfully
wire up the brain to get kind of super
perception of color
um and uh but I think you know already
this phenomenon happens with uh I don't
know what fraction of the of the of the
females of the species so to speak and
uh you know the the main consequence of
that tends to be sort of heightened
color awareness and uh perhaps uh you
know when it comes to human language
people say oh that's a blue that's a
green that's a whatever
um you know an interesting question
would be
um you know is there a kind of
additional sort of way of describing
colors that could be communicated
between folks who have you know those
additional cone sounds cells and now the
whole story of blue and green and the
history of of different color words for
blue and green and the fact that those
were not distinguished in for example
ancient Greek and so on is a whole whole
different story and one that will be
interesting to trace uh you know and
perhaps one would find if there was some
thing where there was a language that
was mostly spoken by women like the
hiragana script in Japanese for example
mostly used by by women maybe one would
find some bizarre phenomenon where there
are additional color words associated
with the fact that many people in that
population were able to perceive more
detailed colors all right you've gotten
me to speculate on lots of kinds of
things and I have to go because I'm late
for something else but um thank you for
all those interesting questions and uh
look forward to uh talking to you
another time
bye for now